yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master I think it's med VG right from
Hungary Raya he's got a German flag
because if i'm not mistaken we've got
the Bundesliga weekend german first leak
and his playing form on a Bundesliga
team so it's in Germany and maybe
playing from his hotel room or something
so on yeah played on this knight c6 move
rather quickly not thinking too much
about this and not sure of this stuff
was so great 95 and I don't like so much
ok let's just drop back d 45 is also
move that it's not necessarily great for
wide all the time simply because some it
gives me some squares it opens up the
long diagonal and gives me some ideas to
put a note on c5 I forgot to play Bishop
g-form it was a mistake maybe maybe a
mistake quite often it is is useful to
UM to get this Bishop exchange because
it sets a piece that's not doing so much
I can the only a positive thing is ok my
position is not not terrible also don't
want to imply that but the night on g2
is really a terrible piece it's not
doing doing anything really ok gain a
temple
was this a temple game probably hmm
maybe Queen B 6 root f2c 8 Queen back or
something I'm not so used to this kind
of yeah it's not a big noni but it looks
a bit like one don't have a pawn on c5
somehow it's got it's not them position
type I'm I'm used to very much one issue
is if I take on d5 he probably takes
with the pawn and then I've got a really
weaker really weak upon wow this is a
strange-looking move rookie three well
what does this move doing preparing
something preparing on the opening of
the e-file I don't do that b5 this was
my idea it's this terrible okay let's
let's go for this he takes on c6 I
recapture with the bishop maybe can play
you five then I mean his whole setup
only makes sense if he is playing a 5 45
and the next next two or three moves and
yeah here we go otherwise this would be
really am without any kind of sense
watching what he what he played and he's
really good player so I'm
you cannot really reckon with that with
move that don't make sense ok I did I'm
still a bit skeptical that this is
really good for white but it's
interesting can I take here what is the
big big idea taking it takes on c64 one
half a hard time this look really really
weird-looking a setup night h5 he
probably just takes and its own it's a
mess I take on d5 their only retakes so
so bad now I need to move any to play
with so now just just e6 night h5 I fear
you he just sacrifices the exchange and
it looks really loose for me it takes
now on night x e6 should shouldn't be
too bad i'm taking the f4 bishop and
also i'm attacking the sea to bishop
what does he playing now it's a bit late
that I spot this but it's really it's
it's a kind of a double attack how does
he how does he cover that mmm not at all
I take with the Queen now isn't this
this is a queen trade right and H who is
also hanging 95 for so this is also a
temple gainer not bad let's let's play
this
and if i play night before now i can
take a 2 and V 2 this is really good
really looking looking nicely now yeah
and what I want want this look to leave
so as simple as that I exchange at least
some some more pieces okay so it's not
really threatening much I hope all my
pieces on good squares I can just use
the a porn that's really not much you
can do the bishop on d5 covers simply
everything the f7 porn and and I agree I
really don't see anything just just push
if it takes its it's even a temple
Andrew come look to be one
yeah rupee one if he moves us this time
this night I'm taking really long here
from they're not playing the best
possible moves I can grab all this stuff
here on the King side as well yeah
they're there were much quicker wins
this much is clear
stay in made I managed haha this this
blitz session really was too long it the
only it the only possible staying male
also every other move wins its yoni I
hoped you two is also staying right oh
my yeah well okay it was a rather rather
decent game anyway but of course and
five seconds is this is rather
comfortable even I mean it's not not
difficult to manage normally ok so I
really am took ages to to win this this
stuff here um no idea where I can take
on b3 and rook v8 or something this is
probably quicker but then this is this
winter also of course but it just it
just takes longer all right at the end
funny stalemate ok thanks for watching